if you're sensitive to flashing images
i'd give this entire video a miss
because it's full of them hello there
i'm gav in this video we'll be learning
how a 3d tv works using the help of slow
motion
as usual specifically the kind that use
these
active shutter 3d glasses i should
probably start saying how this is how 3d
tv worked
because they're now relics of the past
this video
is sponsored by kiwico i'll tell you
more about them at the end
before we look at the tv specifically
let's just go over the basics
of what is actually going on when you
watch a 3d movie
when watching content the illusion of 3d
is achieved by showing
two different perspectives one to each
eye
this process is usually started in the
camera either by using a special
3d camera with two lenses or by using
two cameras side by side to mimic the
positions
of two human eyeballs for our vr 180
series on oculus for our regular speed
footage we used a camera with two lenses
and then for the slow-mo we just used
two phantoms
side by side now the phantoms are
actually physically too big
to get that close together especially
once the lenses were on so we used a
special mirror rig one camera looking
through a mirror and one looking after
reflection of the mirror
and this allowed the phantoms to
effectively phase through each other
giving the correct interocular distance
from experience
i can tell you that this method
introduces a lot of extra cost
and a lot of extra time needed to
complete the shoot i also wouldn't
recommend
handheld shots with this setup so now we
have our two different perspectives
left and right eye the next challenge is
only showing the correct perspective
to each eye in a vr headset it's
actually quite simple you just have each
eye look at a different screen
or look through a different lens looking
at different areas on the same screen
i won't go into too much detail about
the other methods there's great videos
online already but in a movie theater
you would typically
project both perspectives using
differently polarized light and then
unpowered glasses would filter those
correctly into each eye you can also use
anaglyph which typically uses
red and blue filtering to show each
perspective to each eye we actually use
this out in the field just to make sure
our footage was looking correct before
we could properly get it into
post-production
but it is a pretty ugly way to view 3d
content because the colors are just all
over the place
that brings us on to this tv it's
actually a plasma
3d tv which i bought secondhand off
craigslist it's not in great condition
there's
all kinds of mess happening on the left
side of the screen and the stand is
taped on with a bit of gaffer but it
should perform just fine for this demo
the reason i went for plasma is that we
can actually get a bit of a double
whammy here i've shown how
crt screens work oled screens work and
how
regular led lcd screens work never had a
plasma tv before and the way they work
is slightly different
like an oled tv each pixel is
self-emissive
they don't need a backlight but they
refresh the screen in
multiple pulses per frame the entire
screen can't be lit at full brightness
so it ends up doing very short duration
pulses of different information in the
frame
persistence of vision in your brain
causes you just to see the complete
image
this is known as the subfield drive
which often occurs
up to 10 times per frame and the pulses
seem to last
slightly different lengths depending on
where they are in building the frame
here i've stacked the results of each
individual pulse
without even realizing it your brain
will have stitched all of these together
creating what looks like just the normal
frame of a movie based on what we're
seeing here this plasma tv
probably would have been advertised as a
480 hertz display but that doesn't mean
it's capable of displaying 480 frames
per second
it just means that it's a 60 hertz
display with eight pulses per frame
so the way this differs from an oled or
an lcd tv is that in slow motion
you can't actually see the entire frame
at once
so now if we switch to 3d mode to the
human eye without glasses on
it looks like both perspectives are just
blurred over each other
however if i turn up my shutter speed on
this camera
removing a lot of the motion blur you
can see that they're not just stationary
sat over each other it's flicking back
and forth
very quickly so now we know that once
the tv has completed
building out one frame it then switches
perspective to the other eye
and builds the same frame from that
perspective
this is where the active shutter glasses
come in and their job is to make sure
your left eye only sees the left frame
and your right eye
only sees the right frame and it does it
by doing this using a battery inside to
power
liquid crystal technology inside each
lens
very similar to what you would find in
an lcd tv
it switches back and forth blocking the
vision from each eye
this will happen 60 times per second per
eye that's 120 switches per second
even on films that are only playing back
at 24 frames a second
looking through the glasses here in 3d
mode slowed down to 20 000 frames per
second
we can see that the tv now only has the
capability
to pulse three times per eye for a total
of six
and i assume the remaining two pulses
are used to switch between left and
right eye
well there we have it i honestly think
that's such an interesting way to show
a different image to each eye because
the concept is so simple
it's really just using technology to
perform
advanced winking it honestly makes me a
little bit sad that the technology
has been abandoned for new tvs because
you can get
such big tvs now for so much cheaper
than they were back
when this technology was being used and
this makes more sense to me to have on a
much bigger screen otherwise it kind of
looks like
you're watching a film in a box that's
like a foot deep doesn't make as much
sense to me on a small screen
yeah i never had one i guess i'm a part
of the reason they went away because i
never bought a 3d tv
this video was sponsored by kiwico very
happy to have them back as a returning
sponsor to our videos
they create fantastic projects and toys
for kids
designed to introduce them to science
maths
art engineering this is a eureka crate
so please enjoy
some footage of me building some
headphones
cubico have a campaign known as small
today big tomorrow the idea being that
small lessons today can mean much bigger
world-changing ideas
in the future so by teaching the skills
of innovation
creativity problem solving today will
help them
get a head start better in the world in
the future i've done several of these
crates now and my favorite thing about
them is that everything you need is in
the box
no need to go to the store you just plop
down a crate open it up and get going
and it's
very satisfying not having to rummage
around for extra things
if you would like to support kiwico and
the slo-mo guys channel you can get
50 off your first crate that's any of
the crates
by going to kiwico.com slow mo guys 50
for 50 off if you found this video
interesting
feel free to slap a like on it and if
you like slow-mo in general
make sure you subscribe thank you very
much for watching
and i'll see you in the next one
goodbye